so from what you've seen of social media
what annoys you about how other people
promote themselves and then what do you
try to emulate I mean the only
annoyances his is the sense that you
know that social media you know we're
promoting the movie becomes the
experience versus the movie itself it
feels like that at least sometimes of
you know you have to get people involved
and get them to be you know some
community around the movie and then then
it doesn't feel like it's about the
movie it's about this other experience
and and I've never been as interested in
in that experience as just well you know
this is that this is the movie and the
community will build up around it if you
make a movie that that's good enough you
know and that's difficult to do and so
yeah I kind of understand I suppose you
know I don't know if Kickstarter and all
those things get wedded into it you know
what that is a really powerful part of
kind of you know this DIY indie
filmmaking but at the same time really I
you know is their sides but they're
really deceitful and yeah
and just don't you know and then and
then sides that are really like oh my
god that you know yeah that would be
great to have for something that that
you're making I'm curious what what is
deceitful about social media because I
know I've heard other people while the
same Kickstarter more than social media
you know does this idea that you know I
think a lot of it is just it's not a
very open process for the most part like
people say you know we need this amount
of money to make something and you know
your donated and yes it's a very like
good-natured thing I suppose of well you
know hopefully they spend the money well
or or you know something along those
lines and it's just kind of you know I
don't I in and I don't like you know the
idea of I suppose is like a pure
donation you no sense to me I don't know
you you know I don't want to get the
Kickstarter stuff or mixed up with the
social media or in and I don't have you
know i would say have mixed feelings
about it you know there'd be a good
chance i have tried to use it in some
way on my next movie because i think it
does get people involved and creates an
audience that wants to see your movie
and that's invaluable but there's you
know I guess what I would say is none of
these things come without you don't gain
something without giving something up
and I think that's a problem with social
medias is there tends to be a sense of
oh it's all great and it's not you know
you you're giving stuff up to get stuff
and you just have to decide is what I'm
getting worth more than what i'm giving
up in oftentimes it's not you know and
it's a ver it just creates so many
decisions you know that it can be
overwhelming and I think you know that's
where I see it now is and you know I
don't right now I'm not smart enough to
know what the best ways to use it are
you know to know that I'm getting more
than I'm then it's being taken away from
me to use these things because it's
because it's so much time you know
people underestimate the time that you
spend for these you know all the social
media stuff and and I think tend to
overestimate the value versus the time
and so it's it's just it's really tough
it'll be you know an ongoing thing that
people figure out
you